- Do we look good?
- Do we look like we're on our periods?
- Period sex.
Uh, you know.
Uh, women--
- Shane, what are you doing?
You don't even have a vagina.
- That's true.
- Period sex.
It can get messy.
But is it worth it?
It's debatable.
(majestic orchestral music)
- I'm for period sex.
- I am not for period sex.
- I think if you want to
have sex on your period,
you should do that.
- I don't like having
ketchup on my hot dog.
- I think blood is gross.
- I'm for period sex.
That is my platform.
(dramatic music)
- I'm arguing for having
sex with a healthy,
regular functioning vagina.
- As a female, you are generally
more turned on and hornier
when you are on your period.
- If you wanna have sex, and
you happen to have your period,
I don't think that there's anything
that should get in the way of that.
- What if you have like uh, a bloody nose.
Would you still make-out with someone?
Or would you just wait until
your nose stopped bleeding?
- You're like, really into it.
Would you choose period sex--
- [Voiceover] I, I, I wouldn't--
- Over normal sex?
- No, I think the argument more is that--
- That you should be able to do it,
that you're into it.
- Absolutely.
- I could even argue
that blood on your penis
is kinda fun sometimes.
- Blood on the penis would
be quite, quite the mess.
I mean, even if you have a condom,
there's no way to get in,
to out, to like, cleaned up,
without some mess getting somewhere.
- If there is a mess,
you're making that mess
every single time.
- It's only four tablespoons to a cup
that you release during one period.
- That's mind-blowing!
I, I feel like it's this much--
- Facts are, facts are
mind-blowing sometimes.
- I fee like it's this much.
- Mind as well have her make
the mess, once in a while.
- Nobody talks about
fluids being a problem
when we talk about squirting.
- I've had sex on my period.
- Mm-hmm.
- You know, it got places
I didn't want it to go.
It got on my pillow case,
and I was like, don't want that.
- I haven't heard the disadvantages yet.
I've only heard ew, or yuck,
which to me, isn't really an argument.
- Disadvantage.
Blood on towels.
Blood on sheets.
I mean, come on!
- Do you have a washing machine, Joe?
- I don't think anybody
should tell anybody else
their body is yucky.
Especially if they're trying to fuck them.
- What about make love?
- I'm not a fucker.
Well, that's,
I don't.
I'm not a person who fucks.
- Then what are we doing
having this conversation?
(dramatic music)
- I see the period as the most
creative week of the month.
Maybe she'll let me suck
some nipples, or something.
There's other things you can do,
there's other ways, like
think about middle school?
- Sucking nipples is not the same
as getting a D in your vaj.
Come on, ladies.
We know this.
- I don't like blood.
I'm like, this upset still,
that this happens to me every month.
- If a girl had made me a turkey sandwich,
and I was like, oh, thanks.
And she was like, yeah but I cut my hand
and I got blood all over it.
I would say, oh, I'll just wait
until you make one without blood on it.
That sounds better.
- Women aren't here to
make you sandwiches.
- Okay.
- By the way.
- Maybe it's like conditioning,
that's made you reject
the idea of periods?
- Yeah, conditioning.
- Maybe like patriarchal conditioning--
- Yeah.
- That's made you reject like,
something natural that
happens in one month?
- Yeah, probably
- You're not someone I
want to have sex with
because like, something
natural, and like very normal
is happening to you.
And it's like, ooh, I'm grossed out!
Or like, this makes me squeamish!
It's like, maybe you
shouldn't be having sex.
Maybe you're a child.
- To be fair, I don't think I
sound that much like a child.
- Is it because you would feel shame--
- No--
- If there was blood on you--
- I just don't want it on me.
Like it just grosses me out.
It's not that, it just, it grosses me out.
Just like getting on stuff, and like...
It's not like I'm like happy about cum.
- It is gross.
And it's sticky, and it gets everywhere.
- Everybody knows that sex is gross,
and penises are gross,
and vaginas are gross.
So I don't know, even how
periods fit into this.
He doesn't even want to have sex.
- Against the argument
of mess, we have towels.
We have extra sheets.
We have showers.
- As a man with glasses, the
shower doesn't do it for me.
- So, I'm also a man with glasses.
- I'm a one shower a day guy.
And I don't want to end sex, and then,
and just be covered in
crazy fluids, and then--
- Why don't you just make that
your one shower of the day?
(dramatic music)
The case for period sex,
is like just the case for sex, really.
- I don't think any
guy should feel ashamed
of being a little
grossed-out by period blood.
Ya know?
- I umm--
- That's just me.
- I think you gotta
grow up, and accept it.
- If you're into it, you should do it.
And if you're grossed out
by things, know yourself.
- As Marilyn Monroe said...
(laughs)
If you don't like me
when I'm on my period,
you don't deserve me--
- Did she say that?
- When I'm on my not period.
- Of course she said that.
- You should be with somebody
that thinks that your body is beautiful.
That respects the range
of the female experience,
including mesntruation.
- But, you know you can't
spell menstruation without men,
so, I think we can weigh-in on the matter.
(sighs)
- It's natural. It's normal.
It's a healthy functioning human body.
Period sex.
- I'm not really a sex in the morning guy.
- Not a sex in the morning guy.
Not a sex on the period guy.
You don't seem like you're
that fun to have sex with.